the impeachment trial of president Donald
Trump starts today in the Senate and there
is no better time.
I'm the now to go through some of the really
bad faith arguments that are being made against
this entire impeachment trial so that we can
sort of get off on the right foot and not
fall for these because you are going to be
Gaslight and you are going to be grand standard
during this process. And uh, I want to get,
get ahead of that if we can. So first of all,
there's the argument of the things Trump did,
even if true are not impeachable sometimes
with the added version of, because there's
no crime in what Donald Trump did. Now, as
many of you know, if you watched yesterday's
show or if you've been around for awhile,
you do not need a crime to impeach a president.
We have video actually of Alan Dershowitz,
which has gone viral. We're back in the 1990s
despite now being a defender of Donald Trump.
He said, you do not need a crime to impeach
a president despite saying something very
different. Now here's their show. It's himself.
We showed this on yesterday's show
because it certainly doesn't have to be a
crime. If you have somebody who completely
corrupts the office of president and who abuses
trust and who poses great danger to our Liberty,
you don't need a technical crime, but remember
that because the executive power is vested
in one person, the president, unlike the judicial
power which is vested in justices of the Supreme
court and inferior judges or the legislative
power in a a senators and 400 and something
representatives, we have one president, and
to impeach a president is like a nonviolent
revolution. It is the most dramatic act of
undoing democracy that is possible, and that's
why the framers use the term a treason, bribery,
high crimes, and misdemeanors to suggest the
English analogy to great offenses of state.
We look at their acts of state. We look at
how they conduct the foreign policy. We look
at whether they tried to subvert the constitution
the way Iran Contra did.
Okay, so just don't fall for it. Whether a
crime has been committed is not actually at
issue here. It does not dictate whether a
conviction or acquittal in the Senate impeachment
trial is appropriate if there have been crimes
committed. Then once Donald Trump or whatever
president is no longer in office, they can
conceivably be indicted for those. That's
a separate legal process. That's a totally
different thing. Not relevant to what we're
dealing with starting today, the Senate impeachment
trial of Donald Trump. Now another version
of this is okay, you don't need a crime to
impeach, but abusive power specifically, which
is one of the two things that Donald Trump
is being impeached for, is not impeachable
Trump, of course, two articles of impeachment,
abusive power and obstruction of Congress,
and you're starting to hear more and more
abusive power is simply not something that's
impeachable. Uh, don't be confused by that.
Abusive power was one of the articles of impeachment
that was adopted by the house judiciary committee
against Richard Nixon in 1974. It was adopted
against bill Clinton in 1998. It's nonsense.
This is a talking point that will rot your
brain if you allow it to. It has already rotted
the brain of many unhinged unflinching defenders
of Donald Trump. Second, a whistleblower whistleblower
related talking points. For example, the whistleblower
was lying. The whistleblower committed a crime
by coming forward, uh, the whistleblower.
We should know who the whistleblower is. How
can you go forward without even knowing who
the original whistleblower on the Ukraine
stuff was? Anything suggesting that all of
the impeachment process is invalid because
of something related to the original whistle
blower, don't fall for it. That's a relevant.
Now, there have been endless corroborations
of all of the things that the whistle blower
initially said by people whose identities
we know who were put under oath and testified
before the house intelligence and house judiciary
committees.
Even though there's really no problem with
the whistleblower not being identified publicly,
we don't even really need their assertions
for impeachment to make sense. And I've used
this analogy before. Imagine that someone
anonymously calls the cops and says at 100
main street right now, there's a burglary
in progress and the burglars are stealing
TVs and expensive works of art. The police
show up, other neighbors corroborate, they
find someone red handed. Burglarizing does
it matter that the original call to police
was anonymous once you have witnesses? And
I believed perpetrator and evidence of the
crime. No, it doesn't make any difference.
In fact, even if the first call wrongly said,
they're stealing TVs and works of art, and
when police show up, they say, Oh no. You
know what? They didn't actually steal any
works of art. It was just TVs. Once the police
figure out what's going on, it still doesn't
matter that the call came in from someone
who was anonymous or that the caller got something
wrong.
Do not fall for that. Talking point about
whistleblowers, number three, there's the
Joe Biden, Hunter Biden, Ukraine corruption
angle, okay? And there's a couple of versions
of that. One. There is, this really is about
corruption in Ukraine, which Donald Trump
was trying to fix. Trump shouldn't be getting
impeached for it, or this really should be
about the corruption of Joe and Hunter Biden.
Now, these are two different stories, right?
One is Trump did nothing wrong and his actions
were justified because he wanted to deal with
Ukrainian corruption. That has been debunked
circumstantially by witnesses. And remember
that Donald Trump is looking into legalizing
bribery of foreign officials. As I told you
yesterday, it doesn't pass the smell test
that Donald Trump's priority here was dealing
with Ukrainian corruption. The other talking
point is this really should be about the Biden's
Joe and Hunter Biden. Now I've said, let's
look into the revolving door of influence
peddling family members of politicians getting
cushy jobs.
Let's look at all of that and you would have
many people in Donald Trump's family who are
guilty of that as well, but it's a separate
issue. It is not what impeachment is about.
Do not allow that talking point to distract
you. This is not about Joe Biden. Next, there
are Republican talking points about we don't
have firsthand evidence. It's all hearsay.
Well, Republicans are trying to block witnesses
who would give firsthand evidence of what
Donald Trump did set and wanted to do. They
can't be allowed to invoke that talking point
while simultaneously blocking witnesses. As
I told you earlier, uh, the white house is
going crazy trying to prevent less. Lev Parness
from testifying in the Senate impeachment
trial. The white house is considering classifying
former national security advisor John Bolton's
testimony to prevent that from being public
and yet they say it's all hearsay. We don't
have firsthand witnesses.
First of all, hearsay is a valid form of evidence
in such a trial. Secondly, it's not all hearsay.
We had plenty of firsthand evidence in the
house hearings and third, we'd have a whole
hell of a lot more of that firsthand evidence
if they stopped trying to block witnesses.
So will we get a fair trial? No. Will senators
be unbiased arbiters of this trial? No, of
course they will not, but at least don't fall
for the bogus talking points. These four or
five talking points that they are trotting
out and repeating ad nauseum because they
are just that they are bogus talking points
that should make you nauseous. The fact that
so many of these talking points work is in
part because so much of the country either
is busy living their lives where they hear
it and they don't really have the time or
where with all our resources to go and investigate
it and I sympathize with that or because they'd
been successfully primed by Donald Trump with
talking points like fake news and all of this
stuff to simply disbelieve anything that sounds
like maybe Donald Trump did the wrong thing.
Maybe the white house, his intentions are
not fully on the up and up. All I can do is
tell you what the talking points are and why
they don't make sense. Let's all now be armed
with them as the Senate impeachment trial
gets going.